for outsiders Capetown can appear to be
a symbol of post apartheid South Africa
the coastal city is promoted as a top
destination for its diversity of food
landscapes and cultures but for black
South Africans life in Cape Town is
steeped in the lasting legacy of
apartheid the system of white minority
rule that has left the country's black
majority poor and powerless though
apartheid was officially terminated in
1994 throughout South Africa
neighbourhoods remained structurally
segregated and the vast majority of
black citizens remain locked in grinding
poverty I'm gonna show you how Cape Town
was designed to keep racial groups
separated and how those divisions
persist today
[Music]
Cape Town's layout provides a striking
example of the clear socio-economic
divisions between South Africans I'm
standing in a Township that reflects the
living conditions of most black Cape
Tony ins poor and under-resourced
without access to running water sewage
or even electricity just next to it is a
white suburb that's worlds apart there's
no easier way to see this than with a
drone from above you can see the state
of the bustling black township I'm
standing it called a Mazama yetu it's a
barren informal settlement made up
mostly of shacks and government to build
homes literally next to the township is
a white suburb that's overflowing with
greenery so here's what life looks like
for most white Cape Tony uns nice
suburban homes with running water
protected by walls and alarm systems
some even have signs specifically
warning black Africans in their language
of course up of dogs inside and the
disparity isn't just black and white
here's the color township of men in
Burke to the left and the informal black
settlement of younga to the right
unlike black townships the ghettos of
colored people are made up of small
homes rather than shacks and have basic
services like running water before we go
any further I should break down how
racial groups are classified here
colored is a centuries-old community of
diverse heritage that might be called
Creole in the US or Caribbean they're
distinguished from Africans who are the
city's cost of speaking black population
while Africans are the vast majority in
most of South Africa in Cape Town
coloreds are the largest group Africans
are a close second whites are only 15
percent followed by Asians and others
the segregation we see from above is the
legacy of an apartheid system that was
instituted by South Africa's National
Party and lasted from 1948 to 1994
apartheid further expanded the policies
of white domination and racial
segregation that were already in place
since the colonial era under the 1950
group areas act the government created
racially segregated areas and forcibly
removed people from neighborhoods
reserved for white people from 1950
until 1983 one of the largest mass
removals in modern history took place
here in Cape Town district 6 where I
currently am had been a booming area in
the heart of the city with more than
60,000 colored residents but in the 70s
the government bulldoze their home and
forced them into windswept housing
projects on the Cape Flats far from the
city centre apartheid dictated where
people could live and move about
Africans were issued a pass for an ID
document stating where they could live
and work they would be arrested if
police found them in a white
neighborhood not designated as their
place of employment the system was used
to bar most Africans from moving to the
city in search of jobs instead they were
confined to living in three blighted
townships in the 80s hundreds of
thousands began moving to the periphery
of the city building shacks and informal
settlements the legacy of that migration
remains today in poor townships like
this one part of apartheid 's divide and
rule scheme was to give coloreds
priority over black Africans for jobs
and housing but coloreds were also
systematically displaced at the expense
of whites and today the white minority
continues to live near the city centre
and in lush suburbs like this one and
the inequality isn't limited to
neighbourhoods under apartheid Cape
Town's more exclusive Atlantic coast
beaches like this one used to prohibit
blacks whites enjoyed their own beaches
like these while blacks and coloreds had
their own beaches which looked like this
today beachfront areas like camp space
still cater to mostly whites but now
it's all about who can afford the nice
restaurants and shops it's this kind of
unspoken disparity that continues to
permeate Cape Town Society studies by
local researchers have found that black
Africans are almost always less
successful than white people in moving
up career paths in Cape Town a
phenomenon labeled the ebony ceiling
effect
the inequality here is so stark that
Cape Town's Gini index which economists
use to measure inequality is 63 out of
100 that's one of the highest in the
world so why has Cape Town failed to
deliver a better life for all since the
end of apartheid some blame Cape Town's
governance Cape Town rests within the
province of the Western Cape which is
the only one of South Africa's nine
provinces not run by the governing
African National Congress
that's the anti apartheid Party of
Nelson Mandela instead it's run by the
Democratic Alliance which grew out of
white liberal establishment politics but
includes remnants of the old National
Party and black middle-class support the
Democratic Alliance dismisses any claims
that Cape Town remains racist but it's
hard to deny the structural segregation
and discrimination that still exists
even if it is more subtle than it was
under apartheid now that Cape Town
grapples with a water crisis the world
has never seen
the stark disparity between the haves
and have-nots is on full display many
black Cape Tony uns have always lived
without running water now others in Cape
Town are getting a glimpse into that
experience as they line up to collect a
ration of water but what about
everything else
well the dream of a truly equitable
society ever become reality here hey
guys it's Deena in the township of amis
Emma yet to check out the next video in
our playlist that looks at Cape Town's
severe water crisis and how it's
affecting everyone be sure to comment
share and subscribe to aj+